ciao a tutti scusate l'emozione ma siete
veramente tantissimi io vorrei parlarvi
dovrei farlo
vorrei parlarvi di come si può essere
rivoluzionario su un mondo strano e
complicato quale quello quale mondo
della ricerca
spesso mi dicono che sono rivoluzionario
io non mi sento così perciò l'unica cosa
che posso darvi è la mia esperienza di
vita
chi sono io insomma io sono sami basso
ragazzo di 19 anni quasi 20 normale una
bellissima famiglia tanti amici e mi
ricordo che un giorno a boston per
halloween
tutti erano elementi travestiti un
signore passa e mi dice ho bellissima
maschera ma io non avevo nessuna
maschera è stata piuttosto divertente
effettivamente io quando quello che mi
fa sembrare strano è una malattia
genetica rarissima che colpisce una
persona ogni 8 milioni di nati sani è
chiamata a progetti di hutchinson
gilford la progeria data dall errore nel
dna che fa sì che è una proteina
chiamata progerina secondi nel nucleo
nella cella e lo distorca come vedete
malattia conosciuta anche come
invecchiamento precoce perché porta
moltissimi problemi che hanno le persone
anziane esempio sono problemi e cuore ai
padri sanguigni all'articolazione alle
ossa
dunque non me la terra non prendere
sottogamba tuttavia io non sono una
progenie
io sono questo sono quello che si finge
un alieno e fa scherzi agli altri perché
effettivamente la mia vita una vita
molto bella degna di essere vissuta
ho tantissimi amici che mi riempiono
veramente le miglior dote scuola come
tutti ho fatto un sacco di progetti
insieme ad amici conoscenti o una
famiglia bellissimo che quale facciamo
veramente squadra e dunque nella mia
vita è veramente bella e p
però diciamo non andava bene quello che
ci hanno detto i medici con un dito
la progeria la malattia senza ricerca
senza cure di cui nessuno si interessa a
noi veramente bene e per questo abbiamo
deciso di essere un po rivoluzionari nel
tentare di far ricerca sulla malattia
così rara
ovviamente la facciamo per i 100 casi di
progeria al mondo ma una malattia che ha
invecchiamento precoce
una ricerca su una malattia che
invecchiamento precoce può fare bene a
tantissime persone migliaia di persone
per questo abbiamo fondato da iper sull
associazione italiana pro gela il san
basso che si occupa proprio
principalmente di raccogliere fondi da
destinare alla ricerca
si occupa anche di divulgare la
conoscenza della progeria a tutti alle
persone a che i medici perché spesso
sono loro che ci chiedono cos'è la
progeria e proprio per questa nostra
associazione è cresciuta grazie
noi non sapevamo cosa volesse dire
impegnarsi su questa cosa non sappiamo
ancora come abbiamo fatto ma tantissime
persone facendo qualsiasi tipo di evento
da spettacoli motoraduni veramente
qualsiasi tipo di evento ci ha fatto
crescere e ci ha fatto ottenere grandi
risultati
risultati quale appunto la sovvenzione
la ricerca il primo meeting in italia a
livello mondiale dei ricercatori
specializzati su progenie anche un
meeting con le famiglie e coraggio
ragazzi con progeria affinché possiamo
conoscerci ci conoscevamo già lo
potessimo veramente scambiare anche
esperienze un grande risultato e questo
è veramente rivoluzionario secondo me è
quello di network italiano danilo pati e
abbiamo fondato insieme al cnr igm di
bologna c'eravamo accorti ma che ai
ricercatori saluto accorti che spesso si
fanno ricerche uguali parallele che
portano gli stessi risultati
e dunque che disperdono i fondi e questo
perché i ricercatori spesso non si può
hanno paura di condividere le loro
informazioni
noi fondando il network italiano una
miopatia da miopatie sono le malattie di
cui fa parte anche la progeria abbiamo
deciso di rivoluzionare un po come
funziona ricerca ci avevamo deciso di
mettere insieme tanti ricercatori da
varie parti d'italia in modo che appunto
si scambiassero darti e se arrivasse
prima la soluzione non solo abbiamo
cercato di rapinare i medici perché
spesso un qualsiasi quindi malattia rara
sballottato poi di la prima da un
dottore poi da un laico e non riescono a
mettersi d'accordo
così facendo invece c'è un equipe che
lavora al benessere impaziente tutta
un'equipe che lo aiuta in un unico
momento e poi una cosa per livello
questo network è proprio il fatto di
essere molto attenti all'opinione delle
associazioni è l'opinione dei pazienti e
vivendo in prima persona la malattia
possono andare veramente di grandi
contenuti
si cerca anche l'appoggio delle case
farmaceutiche è un po più difficile ma
ci stiamo provando
quando
quando siamo partiti la progeria non era
conosciuta non si sapeva nemmeno quale
era il gene della provocasse ci si
aspettava di scoprirlo nel 2015
quest'anno ho 2020 in questo lasso di
tempo è stato scoperto nel 2009 si è
fatto un miracolo scientifico nel 2007 a
boston già c'era il primo clinical cryan
cioè la prima sperimentazione clinica
dove di farmaci venivano sperimentati su
pazienti una rivoluzione veramente ora
le ricerche sono molte in america perché
devo andare avanti perché in francia e
siamo contenti di dire che siamo
riusciti a portarla che qui in italia
dove si stanno facendo veramente passi
da gigante scoprendo cose pazzesche
veramente rivedete dei risultati di un
primo il primo clinical kayal dove una
cella sembra ritornare sarà dunque un
bellissimo risultato
mi chiedono spesso come faccio a fare
grazie
che però
perché non lo spesso come faccio a fare
le cose che faccio
l'unica mia risposta è che lo faccio per
fede
io sono molto credente e spesso quando
di con la gente si stupisce perché non
riesce a concepire come una persona con
la malattia rara posso credere in dio io
rispondo sempre che sono molte più le
cose che dio ci ha dato la terra un sole
mare tutto i genitori gli amici sono
molte più cose di quello che la malattia
può portare via
spesso la gente penso proprio questo che
prende perché uno che crede in dio e dio
aveva praticamente farlo altobello
risolvere tutti i problemi ma non ho mai
detto questo il suo ha detto portare ha
detto chi mi ama mi segua e prenda la
sua croce group e si assomigliano
difficoltà che si vedono sulla fede però
parlando più in generale vorrei
condividere con voi qual è la mia
ricetta per essere un po rivoluzionario
in realtà secondo me la ricetta non c'è
semplicemente perché non ci sono gli
ingredienti l'unico ingrediente siamo
noi stessi siamo noi è l'unica cosa che
dobbiamo imparare a usare al meglio noi
stessi
a mio parere dunque prima di tutto
accettare che siamo non possiamo essere
delle persone che non siamo appunto
noi siamo noi ed è questo che ci rende
forti è la diversità che ci rende belli
e accettare chi siamo
porta alcuna conseguenza cioè credere in
noi spesso appunto mi dicono che sono
riuscito a fare tantissime cose e spesso
non c'è anche gente che mi dice vorrei
avere io la tua forza
adesso è veramente una forza particolare
io credo che ce l'abbiamo tutti
se pensate che quello che nel mio
piccolo sono riuscito a fare siamo
riusciti a fare è tanto pensate anche
che lo ha fatto nonostante tutte le
persone che credono che i disabili non
possono fare niente loro vita o che
dicono dove arriva
dove arriva 2 arriverà arriverà senza
tante speranze invece non è così
creare stessi e proprio pensare di
poterci da fare
l'aifa qualche cosa essenziale secondo
me è proprio che il mio ne fa la forza
dobbiamo imparare ad agire insieme alle
altre persone spesso io io prima ho
parlato spesso di noi abbiamo fatto
oppure siamo riusciti a fare
non è un caso se ho parlato ottimale
senza i miei genitori che mi insegna
solo combattere le mie battaglie e
piepoli che l'hanno combattuta pio x me
quindi non potevo farlo io non sarei
quello che sono ora senza tutte le
persone che ci hanno dato una mano per
far crescere la nostra idea non saremo
niente
l'associazione senza i nostri
sostenitori non sarebbe niente i fondi
dati alla ricerca senza mia ricercatori
è appunto la contano non sarebbero
niente gruppo e lavorare insieme è
proprio una cosa importantissima che
perché insomma siamo tutti di questo
pianeta è un'altra cosa ho imparato che
posso assicurare che questo l'ho
imparato nella mia pelle è che a volte
gli ostacoli sono opportunità la mia
malattia la pro ceriana malattia che
toglie molto fisicamente ma dà anche
molto ho avuto modo di girare il mondo
di conoscere altre culture di conoscere
ai ragazzi con la mia malattia di vedere
centri di ricerca mondiali e piu grandi
negato anche modo di fare moltissima
esperienza e perché no di cambiare il
mio modo di pensare sempre a volte un
muro
puoi non essere un po non essere un muro
insormontabile ma può essere un muro per
salirci e vedere un loop e per
concludere io vorrei farmi riflettere
sul fatto che sa che moriremo tutti
ora tutti quelli che siamo questa sala
il mondo non cambierebbe il mondo
andrebbe avanti lo stesso anche senza di
noi
però vorrei anche che dirvi che se è
vero che non siamo indispensabili
e vero anche che abbiamo la forza dentro
di noi e lavorando con gli altri di
cambiarlo questo mondo dove facciamo
rivoluzionari e cambia volo
croce